gaza is quiet on monday no israeli bombs
no collapsing buildings no air raid
sirens for now
three days of bombardment by israel has
destroyed homes and killed dozens of
palestinians many of them children
the cease-fire began late on sunday
bringing relief and celebration
we hope we will not have wars we are a
people and we have the right to live our
lives in gaza we don't want wars every
year or every two days
now we haven't even recovered from the
previous war
because israel says a hunt for leaders
of the palestinian islamic jihad
israel and its allies call them
terrorists
but the relatively small armed
resistance group enjoys support among
palestinians
they affect heavy aerial and artillery
attacks on neighborhoods in gaza and
retaliatory rocket fire into israel
egypt mediated the cease-fire between
israel and the islamic jihad with
support from the u.n and qatar
because of this renewed aggression the
qatari role was again as it always is
with the aim to stop this aggression and
stop the continuous bloodshed
israel and islamic jihad both reserve
the right they say to respond to future
aggression assuring a decades-long
conflict is far from over
the zionist enemy had a clear and
specific goal the annihilation of the
islamic jihad movement and its military
wing the al-qud's brigade today after
the clash is stopped islamic jihad is
clearly still strong
minutes before the cease-fire took
effect a flurry of bombs and rockets
flew back and forth between gaza and
israel before the skies fell silent
people in gaza don't get to go back to
anything like normal because they're
still living under israel's siege that
is a form of silent violence
against every man woman and child in
gaza 24 hours a day
365 days a year for 15 years so
unfortunately it is fragile this is
going to happen again i can't tell you
if it's going to be in a day a week a
month or a year but it's going to keep
happening because israel enjoys total
impunity
for its crimes against the palestinian
people
let's cross over live now to imna said
in gaza yumna how is that ceasefire
holding now
sammy well here in gaza while people are
trying to get back to their normal lives
uh
many families are mourning and
and uh
in funerals of their lost beloved ones
in the past air strikes uh others are in
hospital
with their injuries but uh the situation
remains very complicated politically
where it's a very cautious silence it's
a very fragile ceasefire like you
mentioned yourself i mean
according to islamic jihad a political
leader here in the gaza strip jihad and
butch who we have spoken to
they say that they have a
an agreement and they have promises by
egypt made on the release of bassam sadi
and khaled awada and that is considered
a promise for the cease-fire to be
implemented in becoming a
two weeks of time frame he said or as
soon as
possible
on the other hand
israeli internal security minister said
that
the agreement of the ceasefire did not
include any um releasing
of any high-profile islamic jihad
prisoners that are in custody with
israel so uh ziad nachala also last
night in his presser after the ceasefire
agreement was reached said that uh
egyptian uh promises on releasing both
basement saudi and khalil awada were
made and the not releasing them is
considered a breaching of this ceasefire
that could take them back to uh or the
group back to uh the attacks so uh
basically it's it's it's a very uh
complicated uh seize uh like very
complicated silence and and um ceasefire
agreement uh the situation is still very
unclear uh it's still very fragile on
the other hand uh un humanitarian
coordinators here in the gaza strip
investigating the aftermath of the
israeli strikes
the power plant has said that by 15 g it
should
have all the fuel needed to operate
fully
today
at 15g
all right thanks so much jumna
the israeli strikes mostly hit three
areas several people including children
and an elderly woman were killed in the
jobalia refugee camp in northern gaza
israeli airstrikes targeted an
agricultural area in khan yunus in the
south
also hit were sites in rafah along the
border with egypt well those strikes
killed palestinian islamic jihad
member khalid mansour
let's bring in now khalid abu hait he is
the palestinian islamic jihad movement's
media officer in lebanon joins us via
skype from beirut there seems to be some
differing narratives on what exactly was
agreed so let me start with a very clear
question
in your understanding has israel agreed
to the immediate release of palestinian
islamic jihad figure khalid al-awada
and the release in two weeks of basam
assadi is that what you
understand israel has agreed to
thank you for having me
the press and the press of uh
last night the secretary general has
mentioned in his press conference that
there is an agreement has been reached
by the egyptian
and that agreement announces that
have to be released today morning and
uh
is to be released in
within two weeks now it's for the
egypt it's for egypt to announce
which one is right and which one uh is
saying the truth and what the agreement
really uh had uh in its uh points
but as we heard from our correspondent
there israeli sources are indicating
that they have not agreed to release
these figures
what will it mean
if if they are not released within two
weeks
what does that mean a return to conflict
yes yes sure
that was very obvious we have a very
clear decision that without releasing
khalid
and bassam assadi
there will be no ceasefire agreement
that will be a break for the agreement
from the israeli side and the fight will
be continued
let me
just go into a little more detail try
and clarify this
there's a difference between
saying we understand the egyptians or
the
mediators or the un will work towards
the release of these two people you're
saying that's not your understanding
your understanding is
not a vague promise to work for the
release of a la walda and assad your
understanding is that they will be
released that is the agreement correct
yes but if you remember uh
the egypt the egyptian declaration has
to be made yesterday at 5 p.m but it has
been late until
8 pm or so on
there was a difference between the
situation between islamic jihad and the
position of islamic and the israeli
party islamic jihad
asserted that without mentioning the
release of khalid
and the basanna there will be no
ceasefire agreement
so the
egyptians have had to take that into
consideration and they mentioned that
into the announcement
where is this
agreement
there has been no release of an official
text of this agreement right
yes now i think that uh it's in the
egypt hands uh egypt has to say what was
the agreement and
how to deal with the situation this is
not the first time that the israelis
break the agreements
uh we know that and we believe that
bennett and lapid
government
had
to make victory at the polls at the
expense of the palestinian people at the
expense of the palestinian blood this is
not the first time the israelis
governments go to this point now we have
an agreement without it there will be no
ceasefire
we were very clear that we can stop or
we stopped
launching rockets and
stopped fire ceasefire
only on a condition that
should be released soon
i mean this morning and that bassam
assadi should be released within two
weeks or so on the the egyptians
they asked and demand that not to be
limited with one week and to make more
time
all right
yeah let me jump in because time is
running out you mentioned the launching
of rockets how do you respond to the
criticism that the launching of rockets
this time
hasn't really achieved much towards
ending the occupation
of the palestinians the israeli
occupation of palestinians it hasn't
contributed much towards ending the
siege of gaza all it's done is possibly
violate the laws of wars by targeting
civilian areas in israel yes
yes but we launched rockets against the
israeli aggressive military operation
declared against us we were but they're
going towards civilian areas aren't they
not just military targets sorry
i mean the rockets are going towards
civilian areas not just military targets
we were not in a venture uh israeli
forces kidnapped saudi from inside his
home and killed
uh
there was
no firing there was no battle israeli
armies israeli army have
made
a massacre against civilians although
they say that it was a military target
you cannot target
uh military officials and leaders when
there is no battle and there is no
fighting going on
all right thank you very much for your
time and for sharing your perspective
thank you thank you